how do I start a difficult conversation
regarding pay somebody comes in and says
I deserve this amount and these are the
reasons why or look how hard I've been
working I deserve money and very often
they put a number out there when that
happens it's backing somebody into a
corner in other words they're setting up
a yes or no which is very difficult what
I find is way more productive is to talk
to somebody and say may I talk to you
about my pay may I talk to about my
compensation like set it up cuz
conversations about money are are often
very uncomfortable so you're setting up
an uncomfortable conversation you can
have numbers in your mind of what you'd
like to achieve that's totally fine what
you want to do is create a dialogue and
very often these conversations go south
because they become a demand rather than
a dialogue they become something that is
proposed as a yes or no um and it
becomes much more heated and much more
emotional so give it a try try and make
it a dialogue where you can have a
conversation about how to get on a path
to get more compensation in the short
medium and long term